[Music]
it could have happened at anybody but it
didn't it happened us
[Applause]
a new band is gonna be something
nobody's ever seen before
oh my god was in my pants but they
looked so much better on me we gotta run
away a toothed plumber
an old man was just play it
comer Bansi they say you're gonna be a
rock star
what do you think
[Music]
holy [ __ ] we want to knock people on
their asses then we've got to give him a
show I'm talking like a stadium show in
the club's the fans that die for some
anarchy so let's give it to him
[Music]
I work for Elektra Records you guys like
a record you
[Music]
[Applause]
I had managed the scorpions Bon Jovi
skid-row
kiss but I had never been through what
motley could put
I'm sick and tired of not having any fun
everything's upside-down and flip-floppy
motley crue no strangers to
controversies Neal West charged with
vehicular manslaughter Tommy Lee and
Heather Locklear have separated it's a
degenerative bone disease nikki sixx has
overdosed I know it's like amazing but I
am leaving units
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Ebru here all week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]